jeff bezos is investing in a company
called altos labs essentially there's a
bunch of jargon included but it's a
company that helps people live longer so
jeff bezos he's the founder of amazon
obviously a very very very very
successful company and now he has made
another investment in alto's labs jeff
bezos some people don't know this
investor uh early investor in google i
think he invested in google when they
were uh in the garage still so he wrote
them one of their first checks couple a
hundred thousand dollars i think he has
sold most of his stakes since putting it
on
he invested 250k in google in 1998 uh
which resulted in 3.3 million shares of
google which in 2017 were worth about a
little bit over 3 billion dollars so
250k to 3 billion wow 250k to 3 billion
that's crazy in google when they were in
the garage right so it's obvious you
know he's got a lot of money he can
write checks amazon was early out so he
wasn't super super rich uh but he had
money and he was able to invest in them
but to obviously make a bet on a company
like google when they're still in there
that's a search engine this is a like
yeah this is a different thing ever yeah
so so it's anti-aging technology uh that
altos labs is creating the company was
founded just a few months ago so jeff
bezos is one of the early investors in
it uh he's joined by a few other people
yuri milner who's a russian billionaire
made a bunch of money on facebook and
other tech investments has joined jeff
bezos uh they've raised 270 million
dollars this company which is a lot of
money but that's the world we live in
when you add jeff bezos to your cap
table uh that's probably a good sign
also so they've raised 270 million
dollars and the stat that john included
in the dock here today
talks about the number of older people
in this country so by 2035 it's
estimated that older people will finally
outnumber the people under 18 for the
first time in american history
that's wild so for the first time within
the next 13 years the amount of old
people uh whatever number that that
barrier is at will outnumber the amount
of young people in this country so this
anti-aging technology is obviously
important uh when you think about it uh
the the uh kind of people are trying to
live longer and jeff bezos is obviously
trying to accelerate that through
technology and investments uh but what
do you guys think about it
what i struggle with is like that's a
lot of money and it's like at what point
with these companies especially the
anti-aging like live forever companies
when does it become more than just like
a research project right 270 million
dollars is a lot of money so i think i
think
me personally my belief on this is that
rich people uh they want to live longer
right yeah and that's they're all
obsessed with it everyone wants to live
longer to some degree but rich people
are super obsessed about it because they
realize that time is the ultimate
currency that they can have right they
can only have so
after some point the money is kind of
like whatever right jeff bezos has
enough money to do whatever he wants in
life technically uh but he needs to live
longer right he's got uh the space
exploration company they want to do a
bunch of different things elon musk
wants to live on mars potentially right
and they want to be able to see a lot of
these projects out but they just want to
live longer and when you have a certain
amount of money uh it's it's obviously
helpful to do whatever you want in life
but they're reinvesting it to go and
create these companies uh that not only
help themselves a little longer but
other people in further generations to
be fair jeff bezos
does look like he has anti-aged yeah
like pre
early amazon to now amazon i don't know
what he's putting on his face well
you've seen i don't know if y'all ever
heard the jokes like uh uh you know i
forget the exact joke like you didn't
you didn't get prettier you just got
rich or something like that like they
say about people would just totally
transform their look uh when they when
they get money because they can afford
whatever surgeries or whatever it might
end up being i don't know what jeff
bezos is doing he's probably just got a
good skin care routine i think that's it
yeah um just really quick funny story
the very first day that i met anthony uh
this was my introduction to him i was
like oh okay so like you invest in
startups like how interesting whatever
wasn't that interesting but you know
that was nice so he was like
so he was like yeah you know i just
invested in this company
that uh basically will freeze your brain
i will not name the company it will
freeze your brain and then you can come
back
after you die so it freezes your brain
when you die and then you can come back
later when you they figure out how to
bring your
brain back to life basically the reason
the freezing happens is so it preserves
the synapses and the neural connections
wild wait so are people actively doing
this
um so rich people have paid to have
their brain frozen when they die it's
like an end of life procedure oh shoot
yeah that's crazy would you guys do that
no
no you wouldn't freak out well okay so
think about it think about it if you die
and then in like 200 years or like we
can bring joe back and then like you go
back but like
people will probably be super advanced
you'll have no idea what's going on
it'll be like a really good you'll be a
boomer you'll be such a boomer you'll be
a boomer what about you john would you
do it freeze your brain i don't know i'd
have to think about it
10 seconds yeah i need more than 10
seconds to make that decision um
tell us in the comments if you would
freeze your brain we want to know if
when you were to die if you would sign
an agreement now to freeze your brain to
potentially come back to life if they
were able to find the technology all
right one one thing i want to note is
obviously
rich people and just people in general
have always looked at living longer this
isn't the first time bezos bezos and
peter thiel actually invested in a
company called union unity biotechnology
a company designing drugs and treatments
that can make a person functional and
free of disease associated with aging as
long as possible so like these people
are exploring many different avenues i
understand the research aspect of it um
i think that aspect is very very
important before you start administering
stuff to people right uh before you
start kind of giving advice to people is
having that that research and all that
stuff that goes along with it uh but
they are altos labs is establishing
several institutes in places like san
diego cambridge they have a bunch of
scientists that have now joined
i'm curious when they will actually roll
out something for the individual person
because like freeze your brain is free
your brain is for like the super rich
who want to freeze their brain the
average person isn't going to be able to
afford it um but obviously doing that
stuff and more technology advances the
more that people can afford it the more
it becomes assessed so do we think bezos
is doing this for
himself or do we think he's doing it for
the technology to advance for other
people also or is it a combination of
both
what's that my problem with the research
thing is like it's not a venture
investment this company is not gonna
return your money in 10 years like this
is a long term and i'm glad that there's
billionaires who are like here's all my
money i don't care or not all my money
like 0.01 of my money um because
otherwise like i don't think venture
investors would be interested in
something like this so
you know thank god for bezos and teal
and whatever who are interested yes in
living longer and probably helping
evolve the technology i don't know the
uh economics on this deal at all but my
guess would be because a lot of the
other deals like this are structured
this way is that they actually like
almost bought themselves a place in line
right and said like hey i'll pay two
three five ten million dollars or
whatever it comes out to be they raised
270 million dollars so they probably
worked with a lot of billionaires or
millionaires to go out and raise this
money and what they're essentially doing
is saying jeff bezos is making a bet
he's saying hey look this is a very very
very small percentage of my total net
worth uh if it works out fantastic right
i bought myself a ticket in line and
i'll be able to use this technology if
it ever comes to to fruition why i'm
still here but at the end of the day
it's a small amount of sun for him but
it means a lot to the company because
now they have 270 million dollars for
them to go and attack the issue and see
if they can accomplish it so i think uh
when it really comes down to it i don't
know if he necessarily again i don't
know the economics of the deal i don't
know his personal view on the company or
the science behind it necessarily but my
thought process is that it's a bet of
some degree right if you're rich enough
to where you can say i can give two five
million dollars uh and have a place in
line in case this was to actually work
out it's a long shot but uh i want to
have a place in line it's not a lot of
money to me it'll give them the ability
to go out and work on this i think it's
interesting i think we've seen other
companies do this kind of stuff with
space or whatever it is and where you
hold your seat in line tesla did it
early with cars right where you put down
a deposit it's as simple as that but
you're just doing it for uh potentially
life
technology would you freeze your brain
to come back
uh
you wouldn't put on that helmet that we
talked about no no so if i i would have
to know what the circumstances are
before okay i wouldn't do it if uh it
was just open-ended where it's like hey
you know you're
because i also like does the brain
freezing work is that like a thing
they've done it till i or that company
that anthony invested and i think they
had done it to like a pig's brain or a
rabbit's brain something super far away
from a human but it was still
interesting
like
all right so i think uh i would have to
know the circumstances i would have to
know like you know we're going to try
for this period of time whatever i don't
want to just like leave my like die
knowing that in some period like it's
open to anything like anything
i could come back as a robot i could you
know like i don't want all these that's
where my head's at everyone i'm i'm
thinking way far down the road robots
and stuff hey guys bang bang thanks so
much for watching the best business show
today and don't forget to check out our
partner sofi they make all this possible
they're a super app that lets you save
spend borrow earn and invest all from
one single platform and if you go there
today and you sign up for a sofi invest
account you can get between five dollars
and a thousand bucks for free from sofi
not everyone's obviously gonna get a
thousand dollars but everyone gets
something don't say that i never did
anything for you go check them out at
sofi.com download the app and go ahead
and open an account
sofi.compomp and make sure you come back
and watch more of the best business show
we're going to build the biggest
business show in the world and we need
your help
[Music]